hello and welcome to this video this is
round nine coverage of Tata Steel 2016
and first of all this video will be a
little bit shorter than the usual round
recaps because I have to do something
real urgently here and I'm I just find
the time to do this to this video and
keep the cover a job but not not much
more time than I can invest in this
video now okay um let's be quick about
it if you have not yet seen the results
and games you still feel informed
afterwards okay what do we have we have
when really gained versus vastly so um
when really I had a win against who you
found earlier round so should be happy
that he's got on the scoreboard with the
win and Wesley so is real rock here or
drawers and one win against Gary we've
got a real culture and this line here
with the check on a four is yeah
something that has been discussed on top
level in in recent in recent years
especially last year when cars and use
this line to be the wrong young so he is
playing much more aggressively than
Aronian with a quick g5 getting form
yeah giving towards King side plate and
they both set up their pieces in some
aggressive way and white on the
queenside black on the King side and the
real amazing thing about this game is
that here it ended in a draw yeah so
here black restless so it seems a offer
to draw and then really accepted yeah
I'm a very surprising end to the game
and it's good that it's surprising it
because nowadays you don't see that so
often that they agree a draw in the
middle of a complicated position and
Mike does not have any anti draw rule I
guess the organizers are probably not
that happy with this kind of draw but
i'm not sure what kind of what's
happening here behind the scenes may be
one of the players didn't feel well or
anything like that
usually you cannot blame both of the
players for lack of fighting spirit so
it's not like we have to to to complete
boss sitting there doing nothing making
a draw not sure it's a bit of a
unfinished story this game let's say we
have Mammadyarov ding Liren and this was
a very long theoretical duel in a semi
Slav white goes from e3 and the line
played here has been seen a lot over the
last let's at 10 15 years this a
three-line got popular and here we have
an interesting position where black is a
pawn up but has a lackin development and
a week winside structure the question is
here can wide win back that porn while
maintaining some kind of pressure and in
the game here black was playing in a
very principled way putting the bishop
on before play see 5 and around here at
the critical moment is of this game I
think we're white needs to search for an
improvement in order to get something
keep something there should be five
check that mayara lady I think after
Keaney seven is probably needing to
nothing here white does not have much
better than taking and after capturing
on a three and green 25 due to the
thread crinia 3 we have a queen trade
and here we already see that we will
probably get a complete liquidation of
forces the whole Queen side will be
traded down this is what happened to you
bishops is six and takes yeah that looks
a little bit yeah like a little bit poor
this kind of way of playing just take
they take everything but why it is
risking to be worse as the black king is
near the action and I think if white has
a clear way to draw he is probably not
unhappy to take it here then here they
agreed to a draw you are not very
exciting but I can't have those
exciting games all the time very
theoretical game probably somewhere
around 17 was 18 they have to be
improvements for white otherwise this is
fizzling out to a draw just like that
okay next game to check is Tomashevsky
who you find that was a limb zoo indian
and the names of Indian ruins sign yeah
this is the line that who you find is
going for arguably maybe the main line
of the e3 demo zone nowadays so-called
carp or variation black is shooting form
the pawn structure that is some is
happening in the game with the black
capturing here and playing now against
this pawn duel this is not strictly
speaking hanging pawns it is only called
hanging pawns um in case of pawns being
or d 4 and C for those neighboring
squares so they are both not protected
here the default point is actually
protected and this is a slightly
different story um yeah why plate light
to d2 Luke c1 + f3 this is a somewhat
unconventional at least in my book set
up here against the black and the black
line but something that Tomashevsky has
used earlier in a game against Alex Len
them in 2014 so nothing new to him who
your fireplace is interesting with e 5
it doesn't look terribly logically i
open up against the bishops but black is
trying to yeah play for play quickly in
the center and try to do something here
with rook against Queen this is an
interesting decision right Tomashevsky
gives up his bishop pair but gets this
pawned advanced and yeah this position
on and now the whole game is some it's
quite interesting there is this weakness
and there's this weakness and the
question is do they
kind of cancel each other out or as one
side on having an advantage if anybody
is better I think it must be white here
because this is easier to attack them
see form and you still have the passer
on the default so I think white is
probably study better in the game it was
interesting to see Tomashevsky invaded
with the Queen but it was traded Chang
and yet around here can go I had a
couple of moves till exactly here i am
not sure if why it has many
opportunities here to make some
substantial progress now you ever take
t5 but it's tough to increase the
pressure while black has the night on d7
defending you haven't b6 and black if
possible maybe we'll regroup his rook
awesome or her work in this case um it
doesn't look very dangerous that same
for black but now she goes for something
pretty drastic giving up the e5 pawn for
the a four part and I'm reasonably sure
that this is a risky decision and
something that may be a guy could have
who had heard him this this happened and
here I think there was an improvement
for Tomashevsky the computer gives you a
form a mysterious looking move but it
has some points that ideas to cover this
reliably and then maybe try to go up
with a king in one of those ways then
maybe regroup the night to e3 if that is
possible I think wyd will be better for
example if we look at a line like that
where black is coming around with the
roof like this and now this and this
here white is definitely better
Tomashevsky could have gotten something
similar in the game a little bit later
in this position he went rookie 3 I
think after that black has enough to
draw but King III intending to invade
was still very interesting at here
I think is better not sure that he can
do something decisive but he keeps an
advantage after this rook c8 d6 and our
rookie aid this is enough yeah black is
giving up this pawn but how can to play
is strong enough can also note the
opposite comet bishops this is very
important a pure bishop ending is a dead
draw and this position already is pretty
dead there's nothing happening here
black is getting this back easily and
with the opposite colored bishops
nothing going on there's also this one
of course so absolutely yeah fine
position now for who you found in the
draw yeah I think she's probably glad
that she stopped the the bad streak the
end she had two losses before um ok next
game I want to look at is a lien of
geary which is a Catalan yageo k she's
also um capable of playing the gruene
fraud other openings but if you would
have led me bet on this being a Catalan
I think I would have I would have agreed
yeah the Catalan seem very likely as
this is what eleonora is playing a lot
yeah here he is playing the night a
three line this is not happening so
often it's a pure pawn sacrifice after
this this white is a full porn down and
it's not going to get it back so quickly
however we have seen those kind of porn
sacrifices a lot in the gruene felt and
the Catalan is nothing else than a green
felt with colors reversed in a way yeah
why displaying the fianchetto d4c for
what is playing a group fell in a way
and sir also probably why the cattle
owners are such a popular opening always
have that good bishop on g2 okay in this
game however it doesn't look like we go
handle a couple of moose then why'd is
getting full compensation after Bishop
t6 they have been games with e3 which I
think actually looks like companies
something like this for example is
definitely some play for wide with jumps
here and gather the really much better
activity but after what you played and
of played I think this is starting to
look a little bit a little bit yeah it
doesn't look like enough here teach XD
595 already losses for white so that
wasn't possible and yeah I enough had to
settle for this kind of situation he
cannot kick hear me okay he can but it's
completely yeah it's not very attractive
um this is what he trotted tried and now
taking the night yeah here black is
really just a pawn up it's just like
that and it's not them it's not clear to
me um if this is still somewhat
defensible for white or if black should
win the way it turned out in the game
what I've got concentrated and activated
his rook and there is some activity
there against b7 and the bishop is not a
bad piece at all but is it still that
black hand um not win hmm yeah we'll see
rookie a rookie 1g six and all looked
like normal strengthening moves 36 like
a stopping g5 and white is trying to get
it in and one thing I'm pretty sure of
is that the next couple of moves don't
help black he played Ruby five and after
Luke c5 traded and I think that here
blacks winning chances are relatively
slim so maybe he round here some
improvement can be can be tried I mean
this is what the engine wants to play
rook to d6 and then possibly look to d4
if circumstances are right
for example you shouldn't blunder the
beep ointment this is what the comp
wants to do the problem with what
happened in the game is that now the
counter playing sb7 is pretty it's
pretty relevant after c7 I think it is a
draw what give you played maybe King to
g7 was a little bit tougher just keeping
things as they are if why for example
now comes a year with a king is this and
still it's not PF black and win this is
however a tribe a clear tribe in the
game after luke t 39 to d7 root d 6 90 x
andrew pieces that was forced it turns
out that black has no way forward and
those two pieces have to stay in order
to keep the beep one protected and the
way the rook is positioned and the black
king can also not activate and we had a
channel of normals king activated to see
three but it's not really that relevant
yeah and now we are shuffling around and
the draw is pretty much unavoidable yeah
again where you feel like geary should
have somehow gotten more out of it but
it wasn't a super a parent there were
one or two moments that i have shown but
i couldn't dig any deeper and tell you
with absolute certainty what what's
going on ok the next game i want to
check is kiwana kayaking battle of the
cause yeah we have a Glin with d3
however and we'll see that it will get
kind of interesting that structure here
it's about it's funny by the way that
there wasn't completely identical
position in the game on Valley navara
this is a game that we will check later
so what they had precisely the same
position um okay what what is going for
him in in this line is he is flexible
with his castling rights in some cases
wide my castle all this is actually
happened what in that happened in the
valley navara game here in koala
kayaking white also advanced the age pot
and cancelled long but I will see how
the difference is I don't want to spoil
any of the other game um yeah black has
regrouped it's night here which is often
a good idea because those squares can be
good for the night c5 to block in the
center and queen to age to f1 possibly
activating it later like with g3 and
Jeff one can be an idea notice we move
it over here and black felt inclined to
take it understandable yeah it's a very
annoying piece however this structure it
looks to be a little bit more
comfortable for white because yeah like
this and this this F or square looks
very promising for white yeah white has
control over that square the issue here
is that this is all nice and good but
how do you ever open up the position
this is very difficult to do it is very
closed um we see an interesting
development here black was piling up on
the d3 pawn and it's quite interesting
kawana is absolutely not minding to to
offer that pawn and in fact here okay I
can took it I think this is an ok
decision however we see that there was
an idea with 94 that c5 porn is attacked
and of course the rook is a text so
black has to do something yeah something
concrete now and I feel that kayak ins
choice now is probably a bit risky at
least
maybe it's also objectively not the best
even though that was very tough to spot
he's playing the move c4 and I think
that this leads to difficult difficult
play maybe rookie to d8 was was a
simpler solution yeah okay why is that
leading to difficult play and the move
before one of the Sun hits and yeah now
white gets some pretty substantial space
on them on the queenside black goes back
to c6 and now a form yeah why does a
pawn down but the d3 pawn is very tough
to to keep and in the remaining in the
remaining structure is good for white
not only for strong and he's got as I
said big space on the queenside black
always had the opportunity to play the
move b6 here also preventing a 5 but he
never did it was an idea certainly this
is this and now be six for example to
make sure that a five is not coming in
the game after King to g8 white played a
five himself and this is a little bit
critical it really is there are a couple
of ideas for white one very simple idea
is to just go here with the king and
take the pawn back play that minor piece
ending not very comfortable because
black has no space and white is better
pieces one white can try to get the pawn
back with f3 knight f2 and then take it
in both cases white is certainly better
what black did now is to like break out
yeah and don't stay passive plate the
move b6 um yeah understandable decision
but still white is better here TX takes
and here a one was played by caruana
it's a good move that's a good move
taking is less testing even though it
was possible for sure
after something that [ __ ] b8 Bishop to
c7 here he had a five white is also
better but I think the game is actually
an improvement over that they drew a one
move directly attacking a six yeah d two
black is just giving giving up that porn
and drive the night back a little bit
something like a 5v5 is losing straight
away with white being able to capture
them Saudi 290x and a five yeah there
were two point saying so you have to
move one of them b5 and c4 and this
position looks excellent really
excellent this is weak white king is
better pieces are better it looks it
looks excellent for wide 98 back had to
cover b6 yeah and here um with some
precision I think kawana could have won
the game the key move is the move f3
just passing a little bit and making a
slight improvement move problem is that
black has a hard time now to find any
decent move yeah waiting most like this
for example can easily be punished and
wide wins there with the fork on f6 what
is that you cannot move this and if you
move the bishop bag there's an ID c3d
five so f3 would have been very good for
white really very good for white um it
just waits for one moment and whatever
black is doing its kind of its kind of
Zeus one whatever black is doing will
harm is position so luke t one was
ultimately played by Kara wanna but this
does not seem to be enough tix takes
I think he has the final position where
I think there's some some room for for
improvement or two to try harder f4 is
interesting here even though it's not
clear that it leads to much the idea is
to take and then use the three against
two for promotion but black probably
will take a check play the King back
this does not seem to be a flat-out win
even though white still retains winning
chances in the game like one okay mm-hmm
in the game after pollution in the game
after f3 black was able to take and
trade everything down and 96 is just
about equalizing but it does equalize
check now why this starting to take the
single-cell pawns but black has exactly
the counter play that he needs you to
eat weight and trade everything down
yeah that's a little joke Bishop age six
and now they agree to a draw yeah and
there were chances here for caruana
definitely I mean not not something we
are super obvious or anything like that
but there were there were opportunities
and they weren't fully fully used on ok
the next game I want to look at we only
have two left right I really was quicker
than usual but I really have to I'm
sorry next game to check is um cards and
Adams yeah Micky Adams is having a
really bad tournament not scoring well
at all is on minus three i b'lieve
before the round and he's also one of
those players who scored
we'll go against Magnus Carlsen he lost
the tone and I don't think he ever won a
game maybe when Karl was a kid or
something but I don't remember I always
remember like that he's getting getting
crushed in various ways so let's see
what happened today okay so carbon is
going back to 14 and we have an Italian
game yeah not not one of Colin's main
openings but he sometimes plays it as a
substitute father and for the women got
this here was t3c 3 the the normal line
that say um um interesting is that
Carlton around here already on move
seven who spent like 15 minutes he's
really playing shares / Leon and yeah
Adams um now played a 5 there was a
threat of winning the bishop with before
so you had to do something a 6 however
is the more conventional way to play it
yeah 93 that that idea was probably
borrowed from Wesley so in earlier round
against Mammadyarov um I think that all
this looks fairly not normal then I
don't see too is something unusual but
pretty slowish kind of opening now I've
got them those bishops will get traded
but this a4 a5 allowed white either to
avoid the trade of this Bishop yeah
ultimately it has to go but now why it
has a little bit more a little bit more
share of the center sd4 is a possibility
and for black gets difficult to do white
also got to f5 here which is kind of
useful no deform yeah grabbing grabbing
space we come to a critical position
around here after d40x 94 here and adams
actually could have taken the porn
wasn't impossible and maybe you should
have done so after Luke takes Knight
takes Queen g-form sorry Quincy for um
in 95 black seems to be okay there does
not seem to be anything terrible
happening to him there is aged for but
after Knight takes Knight takes Knight
back check and King f8 things don't look
so bad yeah the material equality and
something like this and this there's not
not much going on this was a I think
important opportunity for adam said
grabbing that pawn the thing is after
taking this pawn and it gets traded for
the Aged porn there is no more strategic
danger anymore in this position for
black because his space disadvantage is
defined by that pawn on e4 that there's
a pawn on e4 against opponent is six if
you can get rid of the e4 pawn that
strategic problem is completely yeah
completely gone and so not taking this
is probably a mistake now White has a
little something now he's got that
superiority in the center is called F
for coming and Black now has played the
move c6 and this seems to be aa question
but I think as d6 really gets weak I
wasn't sure why this was played actually
it does not seem very necessary quite
often you feel inclined to play the more
c6 because there's a night possibly
coming to d5 but this is not around the
corner in this position as then the
white knights are not positioned
slightly so it's a bit a bit mysterious
while c6 was played and the way it went
here Carlos position looks quite
promising with that pressure on them on
the deep on um yeah here um black
probably should have played a move like
Queen to be 60 look to the seven
just stay let's say important is that
what taking isn't leaning too much there
are all kinds of weird tactics here but
the capture is ultimately a self pin and
something that white will get not like
in the long run yeah what he did is I
think a mistake you played King 2h7 and
now there is a for coming and I think
it's difficult now for black to keep a
satisfactory position probably not
possible Jack he gave the check and went
back right now cannot take only six
because of them with Knight to g4 this
is quite annoying that's something that
white wants to avoid I mean it's not
like losing or anything but it's
absolutely not the best possible
continuation you can still play rook f
one year better his age three just keep
the tension and ask black about the d6
porn yeah and by now it is very
difficult to defend probably impossible
so this kind of moves like King age 76
it piled up and now I think black is in
trouble he tried rooty 796 and now the
exchange sacrifice you don't do that why
do play a five and cement this night
down this excel exchange second like
it's invading but why would the precise
play can hand off the activity we at the
end get to a position here with white
being an exchange of for porn and with
with excellent technique it's something
that white should win however in the
game a couple of things were still kind
of interesting cars and what's going on
a porn hunt on the queenside getting the
material balance to something completely
decisive but in the meantime adam says
established those two points i can
absolutely tell you that i would be
still very much afraid to get swindled
in this position because the pawns
immensely dangerous but yeah calzon made
a very good job of keeping everything
under control there were the art there
was the odd moment where he could have
played better but he never gave a
winning advantage away the a porn was
pushed and like it's not breaking
through on the on the King side it looks
scary but there's nothing nothing going
on before Luke t7 was maybe a little bit
more precise but before also seems to
win yeah this was forced but the
resulting position is still excellent
for white and probably winning there
were three pawns for the night and yeah
somehow it all goes down very smoothly
now check let's play as a min it's very
easy and just have to push the pawns 96
is not the toughest defends it would
have been a lot tougher to win against
Knight f6 but ultimately it will
probably be a win as well after this
check and group to give one that pin is
more than awkward check check no now
Adams resigned as rupee 8 is impossible
to stop or variations like that if black
plays this for example check you
flicking the check and oops again yet
another check so there is a win for the
world champion is really in good shape
now having after played four drawers in
the first four rounds he has gotten in
now is it four wins yeah it's got four
wins right four winds in the draw after
from the last five round so excellent
performance and also a pretty typical
display I think for cars and strength it
comes from a not much happening position
and slowly builds up some pressure and
if the opponent is not playing perfect
defense then quite often he gets this
pressure may make it more and make
something substantial out of it in the
end game yeah Adams is not in good shape
and somehow does not seem to handle cars
and bad at all okay we just have one
game left by here with white against
Navarro yes I already have mentioned we
have the same bull in that's in the car
wanaka rockin game only here in the bar
with bishop d6 and so on plays a bit
differently until place to move age 6
and the thing is we have to look at this
game a little bit to understand better
why I'm a bit skeptical maybe you have
to play that movement we will see
castles night b8 and route b2g1 what
white is doing here is really lining up
for a super direct attack g45 and yeah
checkmate it's kind of thing um and I
think here blacks position is always
it's difficult to handle and what he
probably has to do is to either go for
something very quickly on the queenside
like be five or to play Bishop g4 to
block the g4 move um this for example is
I think a much better option than the
game here after g4 like a Scott 94 and
after this this this and f6 I think
black can be reasonably happy here the
attacking plan that happens in the game
does not work here you'll see don't want
to spoil it so much Bishop g4 is also
move just putting this pawn
this night on this night come on this
Bishop party she fought to make sure
that why does not playing G for himself
after 93 Quincy age does it doesn't look
like a fantastic solution but or 27 for
that matter but well absolutely
everything is better than what happened
in the game because after 96 g-form I
think black is losing I know it sounds
harsh but I think he is really losing
him after g4 um navara didn't find the
defense and i cannot improve with the
help of the engines black now is faced
with the threat g5 and the only move to
stop it is f6 the only problem is it's
not stopping it the still g5 coming it's
a it's amazing how quickly while to
engineer this this decisive attack after
g5 um black seems to be lost it's just
like that um what is black supposed to
do yeah if you take with the H porn then
aged six is coming and after let's say
g6 white can sacrifice him check just
one line there are a couple of lines but
White's attackers this is super strong
yeah he decided to take with the f porn
that's probably the toughest yeah and
now just night takes black m place night
to deform putting that tempo on the
Queen but no worries wide can just go
back and now he decided to grab the
night it's difficult to give any other
advice um you can try move some for
example set of 94 there also was the
move be five but why would also
a very dangerous attack by various means
Y can also just take the six but going
back here on to h3 is also interesting
and taking age six the tech is I think
just too dangerous yeah this is what
happened Bishop takes Bishop to e7 and
now very calm move Bishop e3 the thread
is just age six and yeah black doesn't
really have anything that he can do
against it if black goes g5 now trying
to stop things then why don't take j and
win like that it's what navara tried you
didn't have any time left but it doesn't
really matter anymore other side is that
this is a winning attack Teague's and
rook takes now we can briefly look at
Bishop takes Queen h5 with that your
queen age 80 ever is killing the I rook
takes was played and now also just queen
age five ya bish should be six it's
really not much that black can do here
that angus is too much Bishop age six
that was the principal threat you can
also check something like this check
check on e5 that also is a is a winning
attack but one win is enough we should
have seven check this is a nice little
and sequence of moves where stuff gets
trades you don't necessarily need to
check mate all the time in this position
now Navarro resigned yep hanging hanging
hmm and that means one of them gets lost
yeah very nice attacking we near by bayi
it wasn't and particularly difficult to
spot or anything but still a great
effort or great achievement to get such
a quick winning against a strong player
like never
it's surprising how quickly it went
downhill after Knight to c6 really seems
that g45 is unstoppable so this is the
critical position where black must
improve upon or even earlier and maybe
that set up that kayaking played was a
bit more reliable okay so two wins in
this round for mahi and for Carlton
Carlton and has extended his lead with
this win at the same time why he got his
first win in after eight drawers very
nice and result for the young Chinese
prodigy and no defeat yet and he wasn't
so close to a feed defeat I think they
were one or two moments but nothing like
her completely lost and so while so it's
doing really holding his own very nicely
in that field alright I hope you enjoyed
the video it was a little bit short as
than usual but I hope still jet provide
you good overview of what happened in
round nine thanks for watching